yeah I'd want to welcome to their
playing errand with lakiya played him
before whistling and that was a Russell
emo hot i had a good win so let's see
how he has improved it doesn't take this
time okay yes the very there's a very
solid line for white yep takes it's
probably whiskey yep yeah maybe there's
a more ambitious way to play this is how
I played it a long time ago in the 1990s
feels like really long ago it's
difficult for me black to do much
yeah wonder how can I do something here
let him do stuff and maybe yeah I wonder
is this is an idea to just heck it off
if the night is potentially more
dangerous iam than mine then my bishop I
[Music]
don't know if the Queen trade helps me
but it gets a little bit of imbalance in
the position at least with the double
pawn maybe it just moves the Queen back
after it's not a bad idea probably
absolutely one and it really doesn't do
much in group d 5 the river silly move
actually rookie wanted something that
helps them anyway yeah this is this is
ambitious Sam that's an ambitious move
f6 is of course is the principal reply
if my queen is absolutely short of
squares I don't think he can trap it
down p for Queen f3 okay so group t6 or
any group on the sick friend will attack
a six and A six now he wants to go
reform so I want to go to d5
and then i have a group be a droopy six
and try to win one of the pawns i have
to be modest ya see this this
disposition little things are good to
get at least rook c8 Roxy six yeah look
to be seven assists plan so after watch
out it does it now I can take and would
be six I think I get the pawn don't see
why not it looks temporarily a little
bit dangerous with to be porn but I
don't see how we can support it
yes to be tricky now and I feel really
that he shouldn't be okay somehow I
don't see how however it's Sally Sally
active with this rook some and all
something on the Kings side Queen g3 but
before Hank so is six hangs I mean
you know I can take it so I want both
parts actually still not easy to win the
position so take here all right
completely forgot that oh oh
ok
media I have rookie 24 25 I there's no
other way to do to cover all the main
thread check okay 28 funny check now
captain come on Wow know [ __ ] all about
Quinn be eight yeah what slowly lost the
pawns there I am so I'm reason to be
happy then I got something at all and
it's a super solid line for wild I would
if I am well you know before I have to
feeling I could be stuff in it just
looks dangerous g4 and clean age too wow
that's very cool can you do this no
fortunately not there because the Queen
but that can be set back ok and here i
still would be aid and white is better
that sets a remarkable move i takes away
it takes away the squares for the Queen
yeah yeah you know I said I had some
doubts that I am and and there was
something there was something he didn't
find it so it was actually rather
cooperative her
or fill me at th on to say it was oh and
that's a fair result then I was a bit
better with the material but bungled it
out yeah okay guys thanks for watching